hello hello can hear me yeah good okay
let's go are we live we live Dustin we
are good you want me to skip the theme
song no go to the [ __ ] theme song I'm
in a bad mood anyway it's over 30
minutes late you know okay everybody
Dean Gary Vee
just text your questions and no stress
cause you sipping tea Gary
[Music]
good morning it's tea with Gary B today
is Thursday April 9th I'm in a tricky
mood a lot of business stuff going on I
had to push this tonight 15 a business
call and then that went to 9:30 because
the call needed to go to 9:30 but I'm
here and I'm gonna change my mood and my
mindset and I want to give some
shoutouts to Chad Hannah Christine
Lauren Lindsey it's fun you guys don't
get to see me in the zone often cuz
usually I have a transition but you know
listen when you're navigating a thousand
person company during a pandemic there's
a ton of [ __ ] going on so big shout out
to all my operational CEOs who are on
the front lines who are trying to
navigate and protect jobs and and and
navigate this storm because this is a
[ __ ] storm so you know that's uh
that's rat [ __ ] operating you know
entrepreneurship is super cool when
things are great and you look happy I'm
[ __ ] Instagram but in real life we're
working out here and I've been through
9/11 I've been through the Great
Recession and and this is it and this is
a tricky one cuz its global it's at
scale and so real stuff but I'm up for
the [ __ ] challenge cuz I'm a [ __ ]
wartime general and now I'm ready to
[ __ ] go let's go Justin what's good
so Gary how you do it I'm doing
unbelievable for everybody's watching
right now it's just you know what this
is why I [ __ ] love tea with Gary Vee I
didn't know Sully was gonna be the silly
excuse me who's gonna be the first guest
silly is one of the great athletes in
our world he is a superstar on our
Minnesota rocker eSports Call of Duty
team he has been performing our team
just has been performing we've been
stunning them we're not stunned but in
the Call of Duty League this year no
question given the history if you know
that league we were not perceived to be
a team that is the upper echelon or
there was unknowns we were not one of
the kind of hype teams going into the
season but we have made some real [ __ ]
noise
no short part because of this man and
his incredible teammates so it's so
weird to be an owner of a team and have
an athlete and a team and here it is you
know not just not exactly how I picture
it as a kid I thought to be a football
player and I'd be old as [ __ ] but I'm
enjoying it tremendously I'm proud of
you and how are you how you doing how's
the family doing great family's nice and
safe
you know just practicing from home and
uh getting ready for our tournament this
weekend
yeah we're back on which is amazing and
I'm excited about that so what uh how's
the season been going so far before you
go into your question um this season for
us has been going up pretty well we've
kind of proved to be a championship
contender team and you know that's
awesome for us because we felt that way
before the season now we're going it my
question for you is you know since most
traditional sports are on pause right
now
what are you watching more of you know
if you saw the first couple of minutes
this episode I'm not watching [ __ ]
because unfortunately you know I've made
my bed and now I have to sleep in it
I've got huge responsibilities I'm
working late into the night every night
looking at every angle to grow our
business and maintain our business and
and navigate this storm you know we have
a lot of we're in a business where
you've got a lot of people who are
struggling to pay their bills you've got
people that are reducing their scopes
I'm just dealing with a ton of [ __ ] so
right now unfortunately not even the
news not even music I'm going at it 15
hours a day kind of going hard on you
know when you're a captain of a boat
and the Seas get rough you know when
it's chill and it's in front of you can
go in the back and hang out with the
patrons and maybe have a glass of
champagne right now hand on wheel trying
to navigate it however because I'm
always paying attention through I Somoza
sand doing what I do this is really my
one release each day I'm very aware of
what's going on with twitch numbers and
YouTube numbers and very aware that our
sport is in a disproportionate position
to succeed the other sports you know
Ronnie big shout-out to Ronnie 2k like
two K's doing you know ESPN you know
like this is this is our time and I
think this weekend the viewership is
going to be extraordinary if we in our
and I and you we promote properly and
let people know it's on actually on that
point want to let everybody know because
a lot of people are about to become in a
sort of rocker fans because you're fans
of me and they're like [ __ ] and I'm
gonna watch this weekend where can
everybody catch this weekend's
tournament this weekend storm is going
to be on twitch.tv slash Zeo d-league
all the matches will be broadcasted
there and we play at 7 p.m. Eastern
Friday against our rivals the Chicago
Huntsman so there's a big one for
everybody's watching a hectare in OG in
the call of duty circles and I became
friends years ago he's a part owner and
GM of Chicago this is a huge battle we
talk a lot of trash on opening weekend
in Minnesota on social I'm super fired
up for it and I can't wait to see what
you do silly even you've been remarkable
brother I'm you know I continued you
obviously every week get more educated
on the nuances of the game and I'm just
blown away by your skills and I
appreciate what you're doing yeah silly
Taylor Taylor Taylor sass question
asking what kind of game play explain
the format um like the tournament format
play the games you're playing within the
5 ok so so the games we're playing we're
strictly called duty on the Minnesota
rocker we're in a 18 tournament format
this weekend there's two separate pools
and we pretty much just broadcast our
skills and hardpoints search-and-destroy
and domination it's awesome everybody
follow Minnesota rocker Dustin get the
handle from Team Gary V if it's not top
of your head let's get to Twitter and
Instagram handle up here let's make sure
everybody who's watching right now
becomes a rocker fan Minnesota baby
Justin thank you thank you so much and
me on later hoarsely take care love that
good Thank You team for that surprise
didn't know he was gonna be on super
cool I like the little surprises in the
beginning of the shows it's been really
fun let's keep this going
Cara oh this is this is going really
well
all right now I'm in a good mood how are
you by the way thank you so much for
everybody who's watching right now if
you don't know who this incredible icon
is in media and technology like you're
making a huge mistake a be her podcast
is such a beast
I did the other day it was I'm excited
to hear her perspective on it but it was
the first time we really got to jam at
length yeah and I my phone exploded all
my smartest Silicon Valley like
everybody I admire who I've either
talked to oftener I haven't talked to in
three years hit me up and just said how
great our chemistry was and how quality
the show was it's great you offered a
lot of really good insights I think
people were looking for super
interesting incidents about management
and how to run a company and some of the
struggles and I think you showed off
your struggles and I think a lot of
people don't do that they don't say what
you're worried about
and they don't like review it's not like
you're being sensitive or anything else
or you're like a sensitive material but
you're like hey this is the problem and
I think people appreciate that because
they're going [ __ ] themselves
have you been the last call well yeah on
a podcast numbers through the roof
people consuming constantly crazy I have
to tell you some are minor up quite a
lot it's interesting I changed my
programming around really quickly in the
car buyers crisis I worked on I'm
covering economics I have healthcare
people on I have I had Esther Perel
talking about relationships you know
what I mean like and I had an economist
on and so I've changed up the
programming well the numbers have
increased rather dramatically this is
what happens when you have skills since
you are actually a media professional
and know that you're doing yeah I mean
to your point I mean I've been watching
some podcasts stay on the same subject
matter which which is actually tone
depth during this time good for you I
mean I mean everybody if you get a
chance out you know I know a lot of you
are watching but on your side tab just
Google Kara you really should know about
her career she's somebody really worth
admiring you have a question Karen yes I
do you know my column this week I read a
comp for the New York Times every week
and last week I read about Sean Hannity
with a I mean I've got Fox News and the
information I don't want to talk about
that because those people lost their
mind when I pointed out yes I'm sure he
gets very emotional very tense but in
any case I want to wrote about the PPP
loans and I okay wondered whether tech
companies should take them and so that
was the debate I know there's a debate
going on among startups with VCS and
VC's tend them not to want to take these
PPP loans or these to protect payroll
and they're available for small time
care educate me why would the
we're the PPP route loans but why in the
subject in the in the subculture of
venture back land where you you play a
lot of why do these C's against it well
they're against it because they think
they should take bridge loans and that
they don't that there could be they have
to might have to change some of the
governing rules of these things because
there's a thing called affiliate
companies where they would group all I
got it these companies together
I got they didn't want to do that they
don't want to reveal a lot of
information that you might but some of
these companies don't want to do layoffs
you know and and if other people think
they're just trying to you know call the
herd of they're bad and look look this
may be a great chapter in Silicon Valley
where companies start realizing that VCS
have their own set of responsibilities
and these are not your buddies and your
unlimited cash coming to you and and
they are I mean one of my biggest
grudges with VCS in general obviously
everyone treats it differently is they I
think that a lot of people don't realize
that a lot of their behaviors and advice
to companies is a portfolio statement
yeah and not a specific for your company
Susan or Rick and so you know to me when
I hear what you're saying here I think
I'm hoping that the startups get really
educated that they realize you're gonna
get advice right now from a VC who she
or he is more worried about what that
means for the VC firm in exposing some
of the dogs or things of that
recalibrating not giving them leverage
to raise a big around not the fact that
they're looking specifically at your
business we're a PPP is exactly what you
should be doing and so I think this is
an education time for a lot of people
there's also the populist argument that
these are companies that have
availability of capital presumably
compared to a mom-and-pop store like
most mom-and-pop stores have two weeks
of cash on hand yeah I mean I think
that's where I probably skew a little
bit more like okay well they decided to
start a company in tech during this time
and you decided to start a laundromat
and that is some of the things that come
along with it
good news laundromat 99% of those
companies actually go out of business we
hear about the ones that sell to Google
or Facebook or go IPO we do not hear
about and you know this you've been
through multiple rodeos there are some
darlings right now unicorns that are
actually not gonna be in business that's
absolutely right so so I think there's
pros and cons you know and I've been
been very close to both my whole life
you know there's pros and cons to
running a normal great business that
catch Kashyap kicks out two million
dollars in cash or $200,000 in cash
every year you have actual business
there but you're not going to
necessarily have access to VC money
because you're not going to
revolutionize the world and get a five
hundred million dollar valuation on our
idea reality that's the new reality as
you know and one of the things that's
interesting is watching Airbnb take that
billion dollars from Silverlake and
sixth Street Partners you know they need
the money and if they live and they
there might have been terms that were
tough on them and so if they don't their
dental work yeah and if they don't have
the leverage and they should because
people are obviously believing that this
will happen this will thrive after this
is over that if you're a small company
maybe you should consider alone people
look my company every company what
liquidity and for a rainy day just
became super unpopular savings became
unpopular you know like everything
became offense and I you know look to be
frank I like these events because they
do reset and you get a little bit back
to some normalcy I don't like to say I
like them because I'm devastated for
people that were hurt by it but there is
some unbelievable truth of the people
that got hurt we're doing behaviors that
created the hurt there's been a lot of
people listen you know a lot about my
story at least from afar like I had a
lot of leverage to do a lot of venture
raising and a lot of certain things I
decided to go very practical people made
decisions and those decisions have
ramifications right absolutely it's an
interesting time so you know a lot of
people have cloud cover to get rid of
stuff they didn't listen for all of you
that watch me I'm a very good
communicator where I can do something in
a snap and it can give you a perspective
other people are far better me of going
deep deep deep this is a podcast you
need to listen to Karen what a nice
surprise thanks for being on take care I
mean it a lot of you I know the subject
she touches and it goes left and right
and back and forth
I think a lot of you could get a lot of
value from listening to her show and get
a different perspective deep let's keep
it going tell Johnny what's good I'm
hanging in brother how are you
I Jersey Jersey I'm in Brooklyn sigh
totally what you
earlier I'm feeling the same exact way
while times absolute ABS no my question
for you right so you're dealing with
some of those some of the things that
I'm dealing with I have all the time in
the world right now you would think all
the time in the world and because I'm
stuck at home I'm doing my part standing
at home and I am a man there's a lot of
things
well Johnny she's everyone's like hey
Dustin can you drop the name of the
podcast so people can find it they have
the team look it up it's carrots
it's recode it's Kara Swisher go ahead
Johnny yeah so basically I'm just in
this new position where my life has been
on stage and in recording studios the
two things would generate income for me
up until this point you know now I'm a
one-man tech team were actually
currently on my podcast my show as well
on Twitter being terrible at this moment
and I'm making them I'm used to having
people around me like Anna that handle
things from [ __ ] walking the dog to
[ __ ] whatever it is then he thought
it alone Jesus done the other
now I've got 24 hours a day my brain is
going a million miles an hour how do i
compartmentalize the time you don't you
don't you and I are too creative for
that [ __ ] mmm like don't beat yourself
up
like if the dog takes a [ __ ] or you
don't wash your clothes or you missed an
opportunity or because there aren't
people around you mean you get the
energy you can't go live for as long I
mean I'm 9 to 11 on this show and I came
on at 9:30 today because I had to take a
business call at 9:00 I thought it was
9:15 like you don't beat yourself up
like like you just don't over judge
yourself Johnny you just honestly you
don't you don't like cuz you know why
you're just gonna do the best you can
and that's and that's awesome and like
some shits gonna drop and other things
not gonna be at some point and then and
then you're gonna learn some [ __ ] about
you and you're gonna learn new stuff
like it's I'm telling you bro don't
overthink it it's you know like because
we weren't built for structure bro right
that's what the thing is is that I'm so
used to having some type of a structure
and now I'm trying to create no no no
you're used to having infrastructure
around you perfectly said yes very much
so now I'm this one-man team it feels
like I still have access to other people
right I mean I'm still working with up a
balloon ik 8 and learning new technology
and you do that but it is completely
different
welcome walk me just just go with
optimism here like
I I my speaking career subsidizes my
being able to go all-in on everything
else I've taken a massive hit like like
real seven figures not one you know like
million you know like so like I mean we
I got annihilated with speaking I only
thrive with people around me my team is
like on top of me but the reality is
we've got health you know to come for
you know what else Bo how old are you
timeless I'm timeless brill that's how
old I am fair enough no tomorrow I'll be
34 I love it
what I like is that now you have this
experience mmm-hmm now you have this
experience greed you know and it's
interesting because you say you what you
were here during 9/11 I was not I came
to Brooklyn in 2010 and I think myself
in a weird and twisted way not in it no
I don't want to make this sound too sick
but I'm like I'm getting to witness a
part of history right here uh-huh like
I'm like I take that go ahead no no I'm
sorry finish your thought I know where
you're going but go ahead take it as
it's almost a blessing and in a weird
[ __ ] twisted ass way that's a go
weird way no no no it's not a dark way
it's actually a hundred percent true I
think the same thing this is we will be
telling the stories of these three to
twelve months for the rest of our lives
right and you went to Brooklyn 2010 like
perfect timing
all rocket ship up yeah this is good for
you you're young man you're gonna be
doing this for 60 more years yeah and
you know I won't take up too much of
your time I know that you started late
and you got a lot of [ __ ] to do and I'd
really appreciate you taking the time to
speak with me because I am obviously a
massive garyvee fan by the way guys if
you're on here talking with terrible and
you don't know who Gary is please go
check out I've got all of these socials
listed right here give me on Twitter
YouTube and Instagram check them out
[ __ ] even root one last thing yeah
Kevin Laue gonna sit down and have a
talk because I started a thing with keV
and I want to talk to you about that I
had a sever point let's go I'm timid
shout to me not too long ago about
something in podcast land I don't know
if it's that or if it's something else
but we'll talk if much bigger we should
love it alright like literally hit me up
like on DM with him right now and let's
get this going this weekend or early
next week we'll all right take your
Johnny stay what Kevin's my guy three
hundred and credible label all right
what's good what's good summer what's
good Daniel what's good
Jamie coop wakes you pat
good like Twitter before we get the next
one take a photo of this share it I'm
gonna follow a bunch of you right now
I'm also asking Brandon for what the
wine text of the day is see all right
Remy's already sharing Taylor's already
sharing it is rockin here already I mean
my following you I know oh my god Remy
all these years boom you got your follow
of it you deserved five years ago all
right let's go
screen shoot share it on Twitter also
share the URL the URL of this live
screen with it
for extra bonus points alright let's
keep this going Oh Jared you know how to
win a boy's heart yeah I've got no audio
no audio alright work with Dustin he's
gonna work with you it's won my heart
and he went away true love take it away
from me alright let's keep this going
I got cool I got scared because I saw
the d-roc part first and I said with him
I would run out of gas I got my dear
Rach now I got a much better looking D
rock what's good bro thank you thank you
very tired now you look great thank you
bro well I really had so I've been an
Instagram influencers for a while now
but I kind of know the game of how to
attract people the only thing I can't
really crack down is how to start
working with companies because you know
I'll hit em up hit them up hit them up
and you know they just keep doing what
kind of what kind of what kind of
content are you putting out oh really
as you can tell I have curly hair so
that's really what catches people's
attention so I'll just leave it out in
that easy
so are you so does that mean you're
doing photos in like call it modeling
are you doing funny videos are your
music what I'm trying to do I'll be to
give you the answer I just need to know
what the content is is that I mean I
when I hear that I hear modeling which
is amazing I just want to like don't
worry about what you're doing I just
want to know exactly what you're doing
so I can give you good advice that's the
thing though like I
everything you've said I do modeling I
do I'm just getting to music so my fan
base is really like messing with that I
do funny videos I do all of it can I
give you a huge piece of advice yes take
the three to four brands that you love
the most
yeah about your IG handle because people
want it bought Veronica or anything
she's cute I see what it is
the two underscores rock got it listen
what you need to do is take your four
favorite products a soap a [ __ ] a
candle a [ __ ] drink you know a piece
of gum your favorite candy your favorite
deodorant and actually make fresh ass
ads and then the copy but like yo this
isn't an ad I'm just giving love because
I [ __ ] love Old Spice or I [ __ ]
love Saratoga water like make an ad
that's [ __ ] amazing whether it's a
great photo modeling whether it's a skit
right I'm telling you right now that I'm
gonna break it down for you you know how
you're like super cute and have a great
smile
which means girls come to you right
other guys have to strategize to go you
have more leverage because you don't
have to do that what you need to do is
that in business terms you need to make
the commercials that's gonna bring them
to you instead of you you're thirsty on
the embro all those guys you made fun of
in high school college and now that you
see they're going you're like I'm just
gonna sit in the cup right here it's
gonna come to me you're that guy that
you made fun of with brands you're
thirsty I want you to make the content
as if and then watch the bees come to
the honey okay okay got it
one more question is there anything
there too much too much content no no
nope the algorithm and the way humans
work
there's there's there's you're not good
enough to make interesting enough
content for too much content but if
you're good enough if you're funny
nothing pretty enough if you're smart
enough you can go forever okay all right
you got it yes how many posts a day do
you do I do
great you know where I'm going you
listen to me enough this is what's great
about this is you need to put these four
ads out in the next two weeks and based
on how little you post your set you're
just gonna do two you know a day four
times over the next 14 days you're good
all right do you take yourself can't
wait to meet you in person
let's keep this going on uh-huh that was
a good clip team Gary B that hole I can
title it stop the in thirsty for brand
money that's gonna crush on the gram
let's go Oh what's good Kristin I can
definitely tell by the accent so I
definitely know that judging you a
little chip on the shoulder Ram I
started seeing some of your content cuz
I was doing a message of the day for my
niece's because they said watch them
every day and my son had learning issues
that I had it kind of like pull more
energy to him and there was like teenage
years and it's not losing the client
opportunity right so I started like a
little positive mustard the day when
they said it adding friends like then it
turns up like 25 teenagers then it turns
like all the people my bar want to be in
it so like a lot of my customers joined
in too it's like 40 45 people 50 people
for like the past five years well okay
bomb your content I was like this dude
is my dude like he talks like me he
thinks like me I gotta meet this guy
so I saw that you gonna be in Boston and
I got up one morning I just went through
the wheat wait for you and I meant to
you rock now listen I'm 49
social media wasn't my jam and Saudi
rock was like well if you want to speak
Gary's gonna tell you
have to go out and like speak for free
wherever you can so you came up the top
of the escalator and looked into I said
hey Gary I'm Kristen I'm a bartender I
want to take my message to the masses I
am I want to come in New York and talk
to you about how to build a brand so for
three years patience I've been trying to
get in front of you and here we are the
reason I said to the people in your team
and your team is amazing like I am like
the poster child for your content
because I basically have an anecdotal
story for almost everything you say
basically like I thought a superpower
was when I was a kid my mom was a single
mom so she kind of gave me like that
armor did I thought that I could do
anything
you know [ __ ] amazing yeah like the
you know the inner gut there's there's
nothing like struggle in real life like
around you but complete and utter
dominance here - and so like I could
make things happen if I believed in it
like I really thought that it could
happen like I want something in third
grade so I just thought that I could
really make it always happen shut up to
third grade but you had to pay for the
consequences of whatever it was you know
how do I know you're saying my favorite
thing on earth is accounted besides
kindness my favorite thing is
accountability
but people confused by that because
those feel like very different energies
that's why you and I connect because you
get that exactly so so fast forward so
then like do my life I kind of always
had like just do whatever I wanted to do
high school I wanted to be an actress I
supposed to put a four-year school sent
my parents down it's like it's not
happening I'm gonna go to Community
College because if I want to be a
starving actress not gonna be in to pay
loans so a mom Marty she thought about
it she's like you know what Kristin's
right did some different jobs tasted
some things Haiti corporate America I
had a bad experience so I said you know
what pack my [ __ ] move to New York a
23-8 [ __ ] like you talk about sleeping
on couches rice and beans to hold you
know a whole nine yards and then I'm
it's just kind of a shady business and
I'm just the type of person that I don't
sell myself like I'd rather be broke and
be me then be rich and be somebody else
it's just it's just how I roll and so I
met my husband he was back in Boston and
I say
you know what I'm gonna give love a shot
so I came home best thing I ever did was
sitting together 21 years later
we've had a lot of experiences likes it
us a lot of times he got hurt on the job
was our work for two years with an
injury on a March blizzard a house
burned down in the middle of the night
and now we lost everything we owned got
back on our feet made a business deal
with somebody lost everything we owned
so I've had to kind of fight my way
through things and then my son has on
some learning issues and I really had a
like learn about special education which
I could go on for days about education
in this country but I'm not going to and
I fought for him day in and day out and
after the end of like getting him where
he needed to be I kind of was like a
little bit depleted you know I mean I
yeah you put you [ __ ] you put it all
like sometimes you just put it all on
the field and like it's kind of one of
those like right and and so when it was
time for high school I decided that
we're just gonna step away from school
in general because I think he's creative
and he just has a different brain and I
said I just don't think it's a very good
lesson if you're massively creative and
massively entrepreneurial the American
school system is not for you let it let
it let there be no [ __ ] confusion
look by the way people think I hate
school I don't hate school I mean oh I
hate school for certain people the end I
don't think anything I like I like
self-awareness I like self-esteem I like
I like being real and goodness
congratulations good for you I kind of
started like really diving into your
content and three of your ask Terry B's
that really stuck out to me with logic
Russ and Hasan Minhaj so speaking and
people are my thing and I always want to
figure out how I was gonna become a
speaker I have a lot of creative ideas
in the back of my head my brain moves
very quickly I'm kind of a good think
tank so Hassan was like I started my own
comedy comedy company a group at the
college and I was like BAM done right
there signed myself up for an open mic
and I did a comedy and once I got back
in front of the microphone
and like the audience again whatever
your energy like you basically reignited
my childhood and you got me back in and
like you'd make a video like I don't
care if you're 46 I'm [ __ ] 40 I
basically started doing the comedy so
I'm kind of hustling home life marriage
bar to new tonight and then doing the
comedy thing I did I did your advice of
reverse engineering so last year for my
birthday I said to my husband for my
40th birthday I want to do a one-woman
show
I rented a hall 150 people showed up for
me friends families customers that I've
way down over the years I have
videotaped it put it on YouTube Kristen
be and Kristen cuz that's all I know how
to be hello watch all on like first of
all I'm super happy and super sad let me
tell you why I'm super happy I'm super
happy because I adore you and I can't
wait to start talking like this is gonna
last a little bit here I've got stuff
for you I got stuff for you I'm
devastated because I don't have any fans
anymore because they all love you so
much right now it's over so put up your
handle on how many subscribers do you
have on YouTube right now Dustin get me
the count or Kristen you probably know I
don't know exactly
don't worry don't worry
and how many followers do we have there
okay watch this I'm actually gonna watch
it in real time this is gonna be the
most fun of my whole day because I
promise you everybody here loves you
more than me now and so it's devastating
for me my career is over but yours is
about to be yeah
when I'm finished can you please hook me
up can you like at least like like you
know maybe put me on as the opening act
to your your speeches or something just
follow okay I just followed you so
you're at 11:05 you already at 11:14
it's moving 11:20 no no put it back up
Dustin let's get this thing completely
out of 1137 I want I want every [ __ ]
person who's falling right now because
you know what the energy is if you like
me you like her 1168 this is YouTube
YouTube
it's rim your 1200 already it's just
happening 12 11 12 24 12 36 Christian
your life is about to change
12:53 it's just happening now 1271 1290
1308 1323 1336 1348 13 62 13 80 13 94 14
14 14 26 1450 I always want to do sit
down listen is Kristin what Kristin you
basically are siphoning my whole fan
base right now you should start last
call with Kristin as a YouTube live
started tonight and [ __ ] go both but
you know my team will help you team get
somebody Chris would I know why do you
think I'm you knew my team I got this
you see why I interrupted everybody I
know the [ __ ] answers before the
questions are coming out of his mouth
you're mad at me and think I'm rude I'm
not I'm just trying to help bastard and
do it yeah like what do you want for me
I'm not come from I'm not mean I'm not a
gaseous I don't mind other people
talking among people talking I just let
me say it I'm [ __ ] I'm good for my
podcast I'm sorry I help people get to
more [ __ ] if you want to hear what their
thoughts are on that
there are 800 [ __ ] thousand other
podcasts I'm not trying to interrupt I'm
trying to get more [ __ ] out for you I'm
sorry that I [ __ ] know with people
can do and say before they do it
it's my [ __ ] I'm sorry of course one
of the things I try to do a lot is not
do that like when I give advice like am
i taking that advice because I don't
want that well [ __ ] you you'd like I
don't want that callback you know what I
mean yeah mm yeah go ahead I'm listening
but hold on Chrissa 2,100 followers now
out here Kristen we're doubling out here
this Kristen this is why I love life
you've been trying to get in front of me
for three years
like like you never know where life goes
you know like if we would have met if we
would have met you know if you would
have gotten an email from d-roc and said
15 minutes with Gary in New York you
would have been like oh my god right and
it would have an epic yes like this is
gonna change your career yeah
people are following you right now and
we have similar energies this is gonna
change your life
this this is gonna change your life I
know what's happening here I'm not
confused
calling [ __ ] the McCormick's very Boston
thank you
I like that [ __ ] the McCormick's how do
i [ __ ] the crafts or the Bradys or the
Edelman's you know yeah anyway we both
ending every night live on YouTube and
Facebook and IG TV and all these people
could be watching you're at 2200
according to bat buildin ya can see the
thing is like the reason like when it's
hard for me to talk to the camera is
because I love the people and so when
the quarantine happened I started
talking to the camera just directly like
the way you talked about doing that
because I was trying to help people kind
of navigate mentally through this
because it's it's uncharted territories
for a lot of people and I kind of
disrupted everybody's life so I'm trying
to keep people positive and try to where
you would tick-tock ah I knew I had to
figure it out because again I know that
I had to figure out how it was gonna
for me like I know you say just get on
there and make stuff and now the story
time and I found the real talk and some
of that and I love to dance like an
old-school like really you're also a
comedian and cop
Christon you're gonna be a superstar on
tick-tock if you make three tic TOCs a
day you're gonna be bigger than me on
tick-tock yeah yeah yeah you are like me
but but you look like a happy face I'm
coming out here trying to [ __ ]
strangle people's happiness you're gonna
get that like you're gonna crush you
understand that this is it don't let the
phone ring Chris and that nose you
lookin knew you could will things back
then I don't even [ __ ] about the burnt
house or the [ __ ] to your thing or if
the [ __ ] life to New York City suck
[ __ ] [ __ ] all that we got 15 more years
to me a [ __ ] superstar that is your
destiny here we are today in fact hunter
beside facts I agree with you I'm ready
to do it
Kristen if you if you do not do happy
hour of our time or the [ __ ] you call it
tonight at 7:00 to 8:00 p.m. and bring
people on and my team's gonna stay on
with you Dustin's gonna pass you to
somebody right now we're gonna literally
handhold you to build out the
infrastructure to how to do it okay
I'm going to get in the car doink Ovid
drive across state lines I don't give a
[ __ ] if Rhode Island tries to stop me
I'm gonna drive right through those
[ __ ] I'm gonna come to your house and
I'm gonna burn your [ __ ] house down
okay if I don't see you on tonight you
got it take care bye Kristin Kristin
bean Kristin follow me on all platforms
especially YouTube and Instagram
hopefully that's her hopefully that's
her tik-tok as well let's keep this
going
that was fun Jared hey Gary how's it
going man really good bro I'm [ __ ]
feeling your shirt bro you got me fired
up I saw you two years ago in Houston we
did that keynote with like George Bush
and all them I think I caught your
attention the front row
to the same number I remember good to
see you man hey first of all thank you
for everything you've done man I'd
surely believe you're the one of the
biggest reasons I'm even still here
breathing today and practicing my
question for the last three days try I
think I've already kind of worked the
answer I know what you're gonna say what
I'm kind of working with this like using
patients as delusion coming holding
myself accountable holding myself
accountable and dwelling thing I could
have done more yesterday like I did some
good like you know I mean like accepting
that like where does where does
gratitude become contentment that's a
that's a great question ambition become
like like yes I want more but like I'm
so thankful for what I have already like
in spite of nothing like everything I
have I don't have that struggle but I
wish I kind of did now but um like how
do you find that balance and I think
you're just gonna look at me and say
it's self awareness like I know when I'm
being a lazy [ __ ] and I know when I've
done but infection yes but I actually
think it's a little bit different than
that actually it's not self-awareness
for me maybe it is the right answer for
you but let me go where I'm going you're
overthinking it no [ __ ] you know you're
overthinking it like do me a favor don't
analyze tomorrow excuse me yesterday
stop analyzing yesterday and that's the
thing like I don't have like some
arbitrary number you know mean like like
I'm 32 delivering pizzas I know I don't
wanna be 35 delivering pizzas but like
can I sue questioning
I'm from nation can I ask you a question
on some real [ __ ] are you happy dude I'm
so happy bro okay bro listen to my
[ __ ] face what please listen to my
face cuz that's that's what caught me
bro listen to my face delivering 34
being 35 in delivering pizza and being
happy is way better than being 27 and a
VP on Wall Street and being unhappy and
it's not [ __ ] close bro to the last
breath I breathe I will single-handedly
like a [ __ ] Nova try to change our
culture to happiness not money with
every ounce of my soul for the
of my life I'm completely convinced on
this completely brother yeah
and that's in that I've been phony
content like three years dude and it's
like and once I start listen he was like
dude this is like the whole reason I
even had like confidence in myself like
back then like when I was like I was a
[ __ ] up my whole 20s like my whole 20s
but in my head I was like I think I've
got massive self-awareness I've got good
intentions I'm a genuine person like
kindness empathy all that good but it's
like I feel like some days I sit back
I'm like good things happen to good
people
I'm just being a good person and I'm
like you didn't do [ __ ] today dude you
need to do it look like I preach Mac
that's fine that's different you know
listen bro you just might not have
ambition I mean I do because you don't
like what you're doing yeah do you like
the Jets
yeah cuz you wank rip that's Monday Ross
shake planing the wrong time and want a
fantasy league for me what what's your
favorite [ __ ] like what do you do do you
like video games you like music you like
[ __ ] yeah so right now I'm flipping
[ __ ] from thrift stores on the side I'm
sorry do you like that where do you do
that because I like it well do you like
the uh do you like the flipping I love
it though you'll make a lot more money
flipping full-time than you will pizza I
just lost the audio again man you did no
problem
can hear me now now now now now now now
can you hear me now now now now I can
still hear you just so you know yeah I
know
can you hear me can't hear me all right
yo we're gonna get you back we're gonna
get you back we're gonna get you back
Dustin hit him on watch
it's a fun game oh oh thank you for you
but you're only from Australia but live
in England now so did it change that
yeah and I've seen you too man I've been
uh well I've been following youth like
five years now but sort of behind the
scenes never really popped onto one of
these before
but basically just to give you a bit of
context I actually followed all of your
marketing advice when I was at
University styling my own social media
agency was earning like a full-time wage
at uni which is awesome so thanks for
that it woke up at the end of the day
though like I got tired of just cold
calling and the whole service delivery
aspect about it it's great you know so
unless you what unless you love the dirt
yeah you can get the money but if you
don't love getting punched in the mouth
services sucks that's the thing like the
money was coming in my I was just like
miserable just working just 16 hours a
day doing that so what I ended up doing
is making a course to sell online which
is like showing entrepreneurs how to
grow their instagrams and things like
that
yep that hit off got 500 signups for
that and basically marketing that over
funnels and what I've been doing since
is teaching my friends how to do that so
one of my mates is a barber I'm teaching
him how to sell courses on how people
cut the hair stuff like that my mates
Forex to make sure those people are
making courses that are worth the money
that world gets really spammy really
fast where there's better information
for free than what they're selling for
$79 just do me a favor while you're
teaching that I don't I don't begrudge
anybody selling courses i begrudge when
people care more about the funnels than
they do about the content in the courses
and then the person is not getting
something good yeah that's that's my
question yeah that's the [ __ ] problem
yeah cuz at the end of the day I
actually love teaching people how to do
this and I sold of course I've sold to
my courses so far and
I really enjoy teaching people and
seeing the results but at the same time
like my reputation is really important
to me and I know that I'm part of this
whole making money online thing and I'm
proud of you I'm proud of you I don't
want us to say I'm uncomfortably proud
of you there's a there's a way to do it
differently there's there's creating
access just not just PDFs so now all of
a sudden the course could be twenty nine
dollars you know for eight hundred
dollars but it also comes with one hour
of the Barbara Stein on face time you
know just some you know like you know
just something of more [ __ ] value it
just gets so spammy they get so spammy
and people just like at all costs try to
convert on the funnel they put all their
effort in the sales and none of it on
the content and people are buying and
then people sell hopes and dreams it
gets real spammy real [ __ ] fast bro
they started saying awesome to a/b test
and they go I'll show you how to build a
barber shop that there's a million
dollars versus like I'm gonna show you
the craft of like it can get really bad
really fast and ninety-eight percent of
what I see is really really bad which is
why I putting pressure on the game do
the reverse and put out decks that are
[ __ ] fire for free that then kids
like you take and repackage and sell
yeah yeah
pretty much I mean it's that sort of
what I teach my core so it's not can I
can I give you a very good piece of
advice yeah never pick money yeah you
have a moral compass and you're smart
enough to believe in reputation cuz you
can never get away from who you were on
the internet yeah and you're young yeah
leave money on the table yeah saying
like without obviously because I all
still want to help people like build
stuff I don't want to put out like a ton
of free content so do that so do that
with zero thought of what it's gonna
mean to your funnel yes the second you
think about your funnel the content
becomes manipulation
not education because subconsciously
even if you're a good kid like you
you're a good kid I could black and wake
me subconsciously you're in that place
yeah yeah look bill says information
should be free I I don't necessarily
agree with that Dustin completely like
you can sell information my big thing is
people buy information every day books
cost money Cable cost money like
everything cut can cost money my big
thing is do you feel great about what
you're selling you know you are do you
like your reputation does your head go
on the pillow easily there's so many
people that sell things that put people
out of business
but they made $4,000 on the course yeah
yeah you can you can navigate this you
can make money by creating a course that
also comes with a virtual keynote which
also comes with a one-hour session for
eight weeks whether you're giving a lot
of value and you can and you can change
adjectives and pictures because the
pictures that convert to the sale are
alluding to [ __ ] 99% of the time and
you know it and I know it's not yeah and
literally that's cuz I'm running these
funnels and adverse nobody I'm not doing
the rental and beginning stuff that's
fast lane I never do that and I'm never
gonna like honesty is everything to me
transparency as well so I would just
that's my question really is how to
damage easy don't compromise for money
yeah though you're gonna make you're
gonna make less money after this call
and be thirty thousand times happier
that's what I do well I can be the
richest of them all there's not a
[ __ ] Lamborghini or a funnel that can
beat me if I went that route I'm most
charismatic I'm the smartest I'm the
hardest-working I'm the [ __ ] best and
a lot of those [ __ ] make more money
than me because they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah I guess what they make more money
than me in 2018 2019 2020 but talk to me
about 21 22 31 42 48 your [ __ ] kid
don't ruin your reputation for a couple
[ __ ]
hundred thousand bucks yeah I mean I
want to do what you do and what rusted
as well build a catalogue of free
content and then but the problem is I've
already sold these courses and my
courses are good like I'm I work hard on
these courses it's not like make a bit
make a video and say I really worked
hard least I felt great about him but
I'm making a pivot yeah yeah but like
all the people have already bought the
courses won't they be like all this
information is free now no I'm angry
though just spend look because they got
their ROI and things change I mean I
mean I'm selling look let me there's a
good plug wine text I'm Adam if you're
in the US I would make you buy but you
got off easy
worry about the sell of wine today
that we we have sold for thirty two
dollars a bottle a Chardonnay
everybody sells for forty bucks a bottle
and we're gonna sell it on wine techs
today for 1980 or something like that
people can be happy but things change -
Adam - Chuck comes out and they're gonna
be happy that you gave them a strategy
on tick-tock yeah you have no problems
with that that is a non-event
yeah when somebody in eight months comes
to B's like I want a refund you [ __ ]
do this you're gonna say no sir I'm
sorry at that point it was selling I
pivot in my business I know you got
value out of that I'm proud of that
let's move on yeah okay so just put
everything out for three give them the
right not give them everything and then
if they need it I'm here to give it for
free like crazy and then also creates
something called you know access with
Adam where you charge people two
thousand dollars a month to hang out
with you and drink tea do you ever check
a charge for this right now yeah Adam on
some real [ __ ] on some real [ __ ] don't
don't flatter me because we're trying to
educate and help people well what would
you pay if if I came out a week oh
forget about the pack that you'd be like
why did you do this you [ __ ] change
[ __ ] you you don't forget about that
yeah if a week two weeks ago I said I'm
being tea with Gary Vee behind a closed
door it's two hours a day you could be
on I'm doing it the whole time on some
real [ __ ]
don't don't fluff the number just out of
curiosity what do you think you
paid for the month of that ya know how
much on some real [ __ ]
forget about what you've done what what
do you think you would have paid
attention good I if I put it out for
1800 you would have been pumped and
[ __ ] a hundred thousand people would
have signed up but is this like just for
an hour or I would I'm making did you
follow me let's say two weeks ago I'm a
pretend hey guys I'm doing tea with Gary
Vee it's a membership thing you got to
pay to be part of it you get to watch
all the content you get to be in the
comments yes then about but not public
and free closed and paid for smaller
group but I'm for the whole time for a
month two hours a day two hours a day
that's that's actually yeah yeah well
I'm here to give you ideas I'm here to
[ __ ] help for free cuz I want you to
do that the reason I want to just
release everything monetize that I get
it I get it
the bottom line is lobotomize you
looking at here from elisa king of 50
bucks to hustle time at 10k a month the
bottom line is I probably could have
made right now when people need be more
scared right now
right now people would need me put up
the $50 one oh you know Dustin no throw
to 10k one you know like you know but
like you know you got Shane goes 100 you
know hunted smaller group a hundred
thousand people yeah I mean like if I
went all out and sold yeah there's a lot
of ways to do it
[ __ ] ads that allude to fake
promises on the Internet
to sell a product that is just [ __ ]
content that if somebody took the four
hours they could gather it on YouTube
and the Internet it's not gonna lead to
a sustained legacy I can promise you
that it you might make some cash upfront
but at what expense money that's why I
started this because I've been the video
I bought so many courses without content
for free and if you need to monetize I
do think a group virtually that gets two
hours your time once
a week for the whole year a lot of those
people would pay actually can you see oh
you can't see the comments I was a on
some real [ __ ] and it could be zero
dollars on some little [ __ ] what would
you pay for a month of teeth with
garyvee it goes behind a closed door
just on some real [ __ ] what do you think
you would pay from zero dollars don't
try to act like a baller I'm just trying
to get some data here for you like you
know like it's just you know people can
do it when you bring value you know let
me so give me 1,000 from Koons you know
my own firming my leg thank you that
five to eighty lady you know you know
like like they just you know like
there's so much so it's you know like
there's so much opportunity 500 bucks
for a Michael like like 250 a month like
from you know somebody has a 10,000 like
like listen where I'm at a lot of people
can't afford it but like I could easily
roll in a thousand people here at 20,000
bucks a month you know like you know
much money that is but yeah but that's
not what I want I want to be happy and I
want to have legacy I suppose what
you're talking about then that's the
long game like I couldn't run paid
advertisement to my free stuff cuz you
couldn't yeah you could I have so you
just got a lesson in his brand versus
sales yeah all these people that claim
that they're marketers they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] salesmen [ __ ]
using [ __ ] things literally kidding
me at the other day and what [ __ ]
what that they went to San Diego just to
take photos with cars and girls and
animals yeah literally yeah listen to me
you're too good of a kid go down yeah
you you you started going down the road
you realized uh-oh
good news I'm [ __ ] putting my hand in
I'm grabbing you out you got this Adam
yeah yeah I'll do it I'll do the rest
and Gary being added I love it
take care brother see thanks man bye-bye
people asked about how you have
questions on Joey mughelli here's how
you either hit me up at two one two nine
three one five seven three one and if
you're in America or Canada and you're
not pied on my text properly making a
huge mistake
free stuff access all sorts of [ __ ]
please take a post of this right now on
Twitter share the link that you're
watching this on and this photo let me
just put my tea hold on post that on
Twitter and your question and a hashtag
and the URL this is on right now and
we're gonna pick some of you for
tomorrow shower to the following week oh
there is no sure tomorrow or Monday I'm
some family stuff so I'll be back
Tuesday I know that kind of hurt some
feelings all right let's go Jay what's
good are you doing very well
so my first it's it's honor to be on
with you many great impact on my life by
all your books and super pump to be on
my thing is uh I was I was I was working
in higher ed went to corporate that
worked with higher ed mates has made
some decent money
it proved some concepts that I already
believed in in business this got my MBA
and I felt like you know what this stuff
is the company I was working for was
making a difference in students lives in
higher ed but I felt like man a lot of
social justice nonprofit organizations
could use this stuff
I felt like nonprofits and social
justice organizations are a little
behind their head on empathy there had a
lot of things but they're behind in
methodology so I started reading to help
said this I started helping him out and
I had it struggle with my business model
and finally I stumbled on doing like
small retainers or like a hundred and
fifty bucks a month for a couple hours a
month had like three clients but then
you know with my wife and I wanted to
grow our family health care in the
States
I got a job at UPenn had a second baby
thank God I did because he had some
minor issues I'm sorry eat chopper thing
a second child and had some issues yeah
he had some sort of I'm sorry birth
mm-hmm and thankfully everything's okay
but if I didn't have health care you
know it would've been a big focus a
little bit different comments yeah so I
I am passionate about career development
I've done the business at them corporate
the nonprofit and I love helping younger
people navigate career and passion and
strength to building and hustling and
networking and trying to you know piece
at them together but this new place I
met wasn't what it was all set up to be
and so I feel like I'm I was good wing
like yeah yep I try to make it work I
feel like I I just don't feel like it's
a safe environment in terms of
professionally okay I journeyed meetings
I dread Monday morning sometimes I feel
it on Saturdays where I'd read in Monday
and that but I have a family in the job
and I got eggs and I was care so I'm I'm
kind of worried with this economy like
do I do I make the pivot and do go back
to my little small thing and try to
build it up again or am I gonna hunker
down on my what happens I think you can
do the consulting thing on the side I
really do and I think that you should
consider getting another job the job
market to be wild after this if this
this could shape up super weird it's
almost like a redraft in sports terms
it's almost like if every player became
available and you redraft like like
companies are laying off that record
mean we've had more people laid off in
last three weeks than we did during the
Great Recession in 2008 I don't think
people understand what its gonna look
like and by the way as a business owner
that's fighting every hour right now to
save every job he can it's gonna get
worse but then I think it's gonna happen
that it's gonna come back pretty quickly
I really do like at worst case scenario
year from now when the [ __ ] vaccine
comes people be popping you know
so Jake for me if you were my brother
and that's how I treat every one of
these calls brother and sister my quick
hot take intuition is you start the side
consulting business if you're talking
about a couple hours a week you know at
150 bucks
hey I would try to push that up though
they may be struggling right now because
donations are you know but even let's
say that cuz you know you know 450 like
cool like 150 bucks a month
a couple hours a week is that what it
was a couple hours a month nice I think
you were back out with that product you
[ __ ] work at night you know I promise
you when you hate your [ __ ] job and
you come home and you have to work on
this other thing it actually makes you
happier that two hours of work makes you
happier you may want to see two kids
from where you want to see your lovely
wife but it's still gonna make you happy
and the kids are asleep and like and
guess what we all have to eat [ __ ]
sometimes sometimes there's a war
sometimes there's a pandemic sometimes
there's a massive economy my take is you
start the side business now it may be
tricky you may not be able to get people
back you keep that and then when things
go into the redraft
right like September October January
when it starts picking back up I think
you get another job a different job
doing something similar you might make a
little less money because I think the
salad is gonna reset but you'll be happy
as [ __ ]
which will give you energy to build up
your 150 you do get nine of those you
see where I'm going yeah yeah another
question to you is uh is it i we have
some savings some kind of the the taxing
that this guys doing well what's not
what's happening right now with the job
your are you furloughed or are you
sitting at home or what son I'm working
remotely
dude that's a [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
won the lottery that's true that's true
and that and that's where it goes back
to like um the happiness versus dread
versus gratefulness you have to be
happier now that you're not actually
physically around the negativity right
you still have it mentally but you're at
least physically not there or you more
unhappy or you happier uh I'm equally
unhappy with
that the the unhealthy dynamics
translate virtually of course when
somebody says [ __ ] their [ __ ]
virtually and in real life Jane listen I
think that the leadership of family has
responsibilities I think taking
high-risk moves of tapping into savings
right now is extremely risky I also
don't want you to break down emotionally
from deep sadness yeah I was using just
the savings from getting certifications
on I'm a tech nerd
I love Linux a love open-source I love
about the tech world unfortunately I was
I was so in in the sunken cost of my
other educational pathways that is like
I could never break way to make a pivot
no no your to your to school doubt
companies hire people that don't have
any [ __ ] educate like any [ __ ] a
certificate if I can just you know
people like if you can [ __ ] code you
can [ __ ] code development is like
[ __ ] sports LeBron doesn't have a
[ __ ] degree from a college yeah
you're you're in that framework right
spent you know Ivy League school where
you work at [ __ ] free you know I'm
listening to you [ __ ] that framework
just literally email a thousand people
on LinkedIn and say I can [ __ ] code
where'd you go to school not for that
but here's where I went but I can do it
you'd be very surprised how much
entrepreneurship has seeped into
corporate America all here is one CTO to
be like yeah this guy can code hired
don't [ __ ] get your validation for a
piece of paper that cost a ton of money
yeah well I still have to learn the
process though because I don't know how
to code the internet got it got it
respect there's a lot of [ __ ] free
[ __ ] ways to learn it on the internet
yeah
okay that's what I would do so a great
job learn something at night
listen eating [ __ ] for as long as
possible is always the right strategy
but you have to stop eating [ __ ] when
you know you're on the verge of breaking
and only you can decide that but I'm
a lot of us men and women out here have
responsibilities that our decisions have
ramification on others you know I've a
lot of family involved in my decisions
and then I have a thousand lives and
those people are family to me too
yeah my wife my wife has a decent income
her her benefits package would be a it's
okay which will allow me some
flexibility well that's huge and then a
few and then if you look at everything
you know maybe you don't need Netflix
for a year maybe you don't need to you
know use you know the amazing Dove soap
and use [ __ ] you know store soap like
if you know this is now when I hear that
adds another element now becomes a
function of your expenses to live if you
can you know if you're gonna put that
burden you know your wife's gonna feel
that burden now you want to look at
everything like look at every expense
yeah okay so I got some options - you've
got a lot of options
free internet learning cutting expenses
I'm dumb [ __ ] eating [ __ ] you got
nothing but [ __ ] options even when
for a lot of people the beginning of
this seem like you have no options you
always got [ __ ] options people yeah
yeah and if that one's over that
unhappiness the toxics thing um
definitely gotta get out of there
you gotta get out of there I don't mind
a you know six more listen I mean I'm
like in third grade I'm like I gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here and I was I'm happy
for nine years and some real [ __ ]
brother that's why you think I'm mad at
schools for entrepreneurs and creatives
because it's an ideology or I think it's
funny or I like razzing I hate
negativity I'm doing it because it needs
to be pon happiness for children yes I
was deeply unhappy I'm like oh I gotta
get out of here
wait a minute nine more years you know
nine more months for you as a grownup
feels super easy for a kid that went
through nine more years and he really
meant it I'm not trying to act cool now
it was deep unhappiness of being in that
school system I nice teachers it was
just a [ __ ] shitty world
you want me to memorize [ __ ] that means
nothing
yeah and then and then with
with the piece with Luke which I
apologize parents please if you have a
creative kid or an entrepreneurial kid
I'm not saying let them drop out of high
school I'm not saying like to be a
[ __ ]
but I'm saying maybe take a little of
the gas off the pedal of some ideology
because you wish you went to a good
college or your mom's big on education
like love your child deploy
self-awareness and empathy
yeah that was a big piece of that fire
too when I first started the the side
business thing when I took a full-time
was I was like people are they have all
this information on the table they're
not taking a look at it I want to be I
want almost evangelize I love that you
take it to the masses I was all fired up
we're gonna do this and then you know
life like cause I do like and safety net
so much yeah J & J it is about gratitude
right a child has some complications
scariest [ __ ] you know the next day
somebody's child was still birthed or
their spouse died in a car accident or
like life is life broke my mom lost her
at five
my mom's greatest mom in the world
executed by a woman that didn't I'm a
mother
mmm life your life man yeah I got a
bounce Thank You Jay
thank you good luck may get some
differences out here today man tea with
Gary Vee I'm seeing you guys on social
I'm seeing you on social by the way
anybody who signs up for wine text right
now please leave a comment so I'll give
you a shout-out that you just did
[ __ ] I see your comments out there
people really feel in this format tea
with kateri be better than any education
to in quarantine Thank You nourish
shirts shreds exhuming let's keep it
going
thanks channel Roberto what's good bro
hey what's up do you hear me Gary Oh
clearer than anybody else you got a
[ __ ] whole system in there you look
like a [ __ ] movie star [ __ ]
how are you I'm doing good man I'm
hanging in
there with everything that's going on
you know talk to me it's been literally
almost six years to the day since
askgaryvee episode 38 where you answered
that question what's the biggest barrier
to success a lack of capital or a lack
of time and I think you remember what
your answer was you know what's funny I
don't know what my answer I honestly
don't know Roberto but you're gonna
remind me it's funny how you you know 20
how we evolved over time I one more time
what's the biggest barrier to success or
commit what was it it was what was the
biggest bit what's the biggest barrier
to success a lack of time or a lack of
capital you know listen I value time
over capital by a trillion miles but
it's a lack of self-esteem you know what
you said six years ago you said it was a
lack of optimism which is tied directly
to that self-esteem love it yeah I love
how consisted I am [ __ ] love it
exactly but with that in mind yes now
yes everything that's going on in the
world right yes not just with Corona but
also just like Coronas done something
that you talk about a lot is that these
things don't change us they expose us
right yes this is exposed for a lot of
people the vulnerability of their
situation not just but the priority of
their health but with what their
financial future is their career all
these things all these frameworks that
they've invested in like the veil has
been pulled back like the floor has been
ripped out from under people which is
horrible which is devastating
but it's affected people's self-esteem
and it's also affecting even people like
me who aren't necessarily directly
negatively impacted like things are
going well for me thankfully but like
I'm watching other people go through and
it's like hard even for me to maintain
like optimism in the face of their pain
and then for them I know that their
entire self-esteem has been wrapped up
in the identity of their job of their
career of their earning potential their
certainty and like future their ability
to be optimistic has been predicated on
this security that was an illusion and
because people because people value
money too much bro yeah facts facts like
you know you've watched me for a long
time we know each other like I'm a you
know I keep going deeper I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm in a single Hanley [ __ ]
refrain [ __ ]
success yeah that dude that we had
earlier hope he comes back maybe
tomorrow or maybe Tuesday cuz sucks that
I'm not on Friday Monday I'm gonna miss
it too um like like we need to reframe
success bro that dude is happy that dude
is happy he's [ __ ] delivering pizzas
at 32 and he's clearly was that's why I
asked them you know I'm vibing you know
how I roll I'm like yeah
wait a minute you happy and he's like
yeah and I'm like bro you [ __ ] won
that's it like could you imagine can you
imagine if this created people wrapping
their self-esteem in the fact that
they're kind people and they're happy
not that they make 180 a year and have a
Beemer exactly so you're a thousand
percent right like the thing that like
has made me the happiness is that I'm in
a position to where it's like my younger
siblings and my parents don't have to
worry about like anything right now with
this chaos world that's not been able to
protect like that's the thing that means
the most to me Gary is hey brother I
love you like it's all I know I'm a
[ __ ] leader yeah who did not put it
on me exactly like that's like and you
know like I've like even since I was
like a little kid right I always like
kind of wanted to step up and to like do
that and like help my mom after the
divorce and all these things but it's
like I never had any quote-unquote like
real power and then even when I was
working I was never making it up but
then when I became an entrepreneur I
could take control over everything
because I could take responsibility for
everything but like how like that's a
situation that like I was able to create
over a period of time
like what what is something more how do
we help more people like how do people
that are in the position you or I am and
right now help people to shift this
framework because right now I know the
obsession is they they see the writing
on the wall but right now what they're
staring down the barrel of is survival
and I speak certainty two ways to help
speaking truth and financially helping
black and white and gray know literally
when this was less you know three weeks
so I'm like uh-oh first things I did was
hit up blue and sit and said we're
buying masks at a premium price right
now because by time all the
she comes from China these next three
weeks are gonna suck so I know it can
buy for 80 cents but let's buy tens of
thousands at four bucks and we're gonna
donate them to New Jersey and New York
hospitals second thing I did was start a
tea with Gary Gaetti ya know like this
anyway not everybody can afford to do
what I did on the personal side yes but
weak but everybody can do what I'm doing
right now right so like something I've
been trying to do with my content is
I've been trying to gear more people up
toward freelancing because the world
hasn't completely shut down because
there's still like land grabs right now
in terms of cash-and-carry of like and
the thing is oh there's the opportunity
was real Oh Roberto oh listen brother
this is just exposing like I've always
said like you brought up already on this
call winners are winning more truth like
like media is on the attack yeah like
I'm on the attack
I've got my 15 top executives with me
all unzoom all in our LinkedIn's
reaching out to anybody we've ever
[ __ ] cross paths with cuz we're
[ __ ] offense out here I'm not
dwelling about which customer campaign
me or [ __ ] is gonna fire us because
they can't afford anything anymore I'm
going after everybody else's [ __ ]
meat yeah that's
I'm gonna eat [ __ ] because I'm a [ __ ]
AAA what do you think for like people
that like haven't quite gotten there yet
like for the people who watch us like
right now what do you think is like the
most important thing somebody can do you
know because you used to watch me and
then you started doing it you're right
it's it's caught it's called action got
you it's fine work ethic like you know
what's so crazy you know I'm heralded in
two thousand eight nine ten for crush it
hustle because people were hurting and
they needed some good energy to work
hard then things got good and the last
few years I'm getting [ __ ] on for hustle
you're burning people out there right
you saw it you're always in the trenches
I know you're watching you guess what is
about to become really cool next year
hustle I guess whether you want to call
it hustle that's a bad word now fine
let's call it hard work right
now I've seen the coding I've seen
people with the language I've seen the
coded language play of like people it's
like okay we're going to demonize these
words and everything like that with no
context I use that word that's right
that's right that's fine listen I know
I've gotten bigger
I know you know I know how rap works
right you try to battle the person
that's bigger than you I understand it
all I it doesn't even bother me I have a
very funny feeling that work ethic is
about to be put on a pedestal again you
know everybody when ten years in
everyone's spending all their time we're
talking about work-life balance and they
should mental happy you know I'm the
number one fan I just want somebody who
delivers pizza that you're the best I'm
not about that money I'm about huh I'm
about happiness however you know work
ethic is part of it it is in the sense
that it's the thing like you've
constantly said that people can control
and what you think you can't control
right now what happened in the economy
and all these things and everything like
that what you can't control is the
opportunity to scale up you can control
the opportunity to reach out you can
control these let me tell you Roberto
let me let me make this very clear for
you and everybody who's watching and I
think you know this yeah what is about
to happen is triple A's because somebody
asked what does that mean winners are
about to super shine fake winners are
about to burn to the ground
all those Instagram [ __ ]
entrepreneurs that were spending all
their money to make pretend they were
successful instead of spending time
making themselves successful they're
gonna get annihilated people gonna have
self-awareness moments where they're
gonna realize they're Steve's was a
little bit bigger they're gonna realize
where they sit it's a reset and the most
insecure and the people with the least
mental foundation are gonna dwell and
blame a thousand percent you're a
thousand percent right and you know
what's interesting you said it and it
makes total sense isn't it right now
because when we're under threat when
things are happening when were under
threat you know what comes up it comes
our insecurities comes out yeah like
that's the revealing thing of whatever
we're insecure and we started and we
started miring different things that
boss that was a little gruff but [ __ ]
and held [ __ ] down who was like not nice
all of a sudden she's holding [ __ ] down
and saved your job you're like wait a
minute Karen yeah she'd be a little
rough one
but I've got my job now because she
[ __ ] sold another account we start
admiring different things when things
get scary exactly so it's like you want
like you know what like there are people
who are like wartime leaders and there
are people who are peacetime leaders and
we've had a long period we've had this
bull market to where people have been
very like I think even with some of the
stuff with people coming after you is
because um you might be a better wartime
leader than a peacetime leader and like
you know it's easy to criticize some
whether I'm a great [ __ ] and guess
what I'm a great [ __ ] peacetime
leader what happened with me is I was
getting so big
that the people were looking for ways to
build themselves up on [ __ ] non
contextualizing what the [ __ ] I say and
that's [ __ ] facts mm-hmm no I've seen
it I've seen it I've read there I've
read the headlines yeah and listen and
by the way I've got the [ __ ] bravado
but like no like honestly no animosity
like I get it like it's all what it is
the truth always wins in the end I don't
care if the crowds booing me I don't
care if my home tech man I would be such
a great [ __ ] athlete I would be so
motivated
if the other team went on a 12o run and
the whole and the whole garden was
booing on us I'd be like okay I
understand you fan and now about the
[ __ ] drop 30 in this quarter to make
you [ __ ] cheer my [ __ ] name well
that's why rocky 3 is your favorite
rocky is because in that one with Ivan
Drago like when like everybody's buoy
for ki before for boy no sorry it's for
you right yeah good right right but like
yeah with rocky for where you know he's
in Russia and everybody's booing him by
the end he has half the crowd he's won
them over purely on grit and on working
on the results and the [ __ ] result
well I know how the story ends and and I
want and honestly because I know 100%
how the story ends
I want everybody else to have a story
too cuz I got love yeah what what I
wanted why I think you want to is I want
people to start realizing this is the
opportunity to write your own story
because I think that people from their
insecurities are being reactive right
now I think even criticism of other
people is just being reactive about your
own insecurities Oh
hosing off someone else to demonize
instead of just doing the harder thing
which is keeping your mouth shut and
saying you know what I'm going to focus
on me and I'm going to focus on why is
it I am upset with that person I'm not
upset with what they did I'm upset with
how I feel and I'm projecting something
onto them and so if you address that but
Roberto it's not fun to be held
accountable it's much more fun to blame
your alcoholic mother it's so much more
fun to blame the city you were born in
it's so much more fun it's lame yeah
everything but like that doesn't mean
that those things aren't true
correct so that doesn't that's not a
separate thing it's might I up to my
dearest friends like the people I care
about the most that go into dwell city
Gary you yeah you know you know a little
bit more story college you know ninety
percent of my friends were
african-american dealing with so many
different issues than I was like in
those deep for am drinking a bottle of
you know drinking a [ __ ] authority of
oae when you're now family and you can
go there it's like yo I get it bro but
nobody's gonna cry for you cuz they're
crying about themselves like you can
spend the rest of your life dwelling
that your dad left and that you get
pulled over by the cops more than I do
and it's all true and you're right comma
what the [ __ ] and this is when you can
be a real friend what are we gonna do
about it exactly and you know the hard
thing to accept of that is that it's
more likely and more practical that you
change then the environment and
circumstances change or they're only get
better on racism racism worse
racism is not going to get better in
America to the ideal place we all want
it before you die there are periods of
time where it gets worse like you know
anti-semitism exploded I've got more
anti-semitism in the last [ __ ] three
years four years five years than I did
in my whole life that way buddy and then
real stuff happened how about the man
ruined a nice gentleman right before you
can be worried about all these macro
issues and then your child can have a
product line and that becomes irrelevant
very quickly what about the fact that I
can get hit by bus and die like it's
life you're not in control of so much
[ __ ] everyone spends all their time
dwelling about what they're not in
control of this fantasy that you can
control [ __ ] focus on what you do the
troll get yourself [ __ ]
so what happened for me was like and
again I grew up like you know I grew up
Catholic company and so I grew up
Catholic I'm happy for me is when like I
constantly put Swami back up
I could Swami back up I said every
[ __ ] day that I'm in the [ __ ]
Airport [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like and swen before that nothing and
the 9/11 happens and I'm sorry that era
when I was wearing my hair I constantly
got pat down because of my drugs is whoa
whoa
when I got my tan white and went serious
omission I'd come on yeah it happens all
the time like the thing that I learned
is is like I realize what about what
about the reverse scheme I'm watching my
my white friends cry because people are
deploying privilege on them in this
[ __ ] grew up in a [ __ ] trailer home
people don't know him nobody knows
anybody all the lot of these [ __ ]
judge I never [ __ ] business worry
about yourself just stop telling other
people how to fix themselves fix you
here's what I can control and here's
what I can't like now the things that I
can't necessarily control the thing is
if I work on myself then am i later in a
position to have an impact on that so
like if you care about a macro issue the
best thing that you could probably do is
become powerful enough to address that
macro issue you do that that I doing
them my brother Roberto that's exactly
what I'm doing I want to change what
young men think is success specifically
and obviously young women too but like I
know what my demo I know what's
happening out there it's actually I
think it's you know when we look at our
numbers of 64 6 65 35 but nice but but
young men who are impressionable and who
want that lifestyle I can [ __ ] break
them down I'd become an alpha to them
and now you know what it feels like to
me Roberto you're in the you're in the
culture of tech and social so I know you
need I know you've seen my impact yes 22
year old saying gratitude 23 I like it
I'm changing the [ __ ] lexicon you
have you've changed the language the
code the lexicon that you have you've
had an impact it's not like it's not
bravado to say that it's like it's truth
it's it's truth and I've seen the
relevancy change in like and not just
because your numbers change but I was
there when you had twenty eight thousand
subscribers like I was there when it's
like Gary who like I remember when I
couldn't pronounce your name like I
remember long ago nope but
in that short period of time the impact
that you've had and the scale that
you've had because you've reached
outside of even the micro of like only
business and entrepreneurial people in
social media people use the watch that's
become jacobs post in here keep going
Roberta I'm sorry but I want her to get
your like now your macro beginning macro
relevance to the average person there
are people who are not entrepreneurs who
know who Gary Vaynerchuk is now and
that's a big roberto cut every single
change every single [ __ ] person on
earth is gonna know who the [ __ ] I am
and I'm gonna take that power and I'm do
the goodest good good a [ __ ] all-time
with it yeah I believe it I'm seeing it
i've watched like there are people who
say things like then there then there
are people who do it and i've been
watching and like and you know and
that's where why so many of us who have
our own you know micro version of
success all still look up to you still
watch even that we've quote-unquote made
it in the eyes of other people and it's
why i still put you on [ __ ] like this
because i want you to go to the next
place and next place and the next person
next it's man it's all [ __ ] it's all
[ __ ] gonna happen
yeah and times like this weed some [ __ ]
out cuz there was some real [ __ ]
confusion of who they haze and who the
eff swear out there and you got caught
in front of pictures and videos but
shits gonna get real no flexi nit it's
like like you know real clean so I'm so
happy that people's priorities like this
is a bad thing that happened but you
have to take a circumstance yeah look
look this is devastating people people
are dying yeah you know um but people
are dying every day about all sorts of
things but now we're going to more of us
are gonna come together for one thing I
believe all are going to shift their
priorities like looking at look at what
Jack just did with like with what he
just did and how he stepped up and
everything like that like for all the
crap he gets look at Bezos basis like
you know when in a hundred million on
that 10 million people change listen
Roberto people people have made
decisions about people without looking
under the hood do you how many people's
spouses or best friends hate me and
think I'm a snake oil salesman and full
of myself and a piece of [ __ ]
but they've never spent 10 hours
educating I would watch this watch false
hope all you do is tell people to work
harder and you give it away for
but what's amazing is like literally
right now in the comments I was like me
me my sister my brother my wife my
husband like everyone's like he's a
motivational speaker you mean the one
that's constantly built businesses his
whole life every minute that he's been a
grown up and they've exploded and been
the biggest in their craft that guy yeah
that's cool
like that's cool how I'm gonna say when
I hold up a Super Bowl trophy as the New
York Jets owner what I'm gonna say there
I got lucky yeah it's like so people
don't even realize something like this
something people haven't reverse
engineered and you've said it is you
know that you have to make billions in
order to buy the New York Jets
right so then all of your actions are
mapped to the vision that you have of
the intention of being able to execute
on that because like there's a whole
pathway of everything you have to do do
you realize how much value you know this
but the people in the audience don't
realize this people think that being a
billionaire is luck or scum here you
step on people to do that and everything
like that the only real way aside from
inheriting money and thrust leaving it
to get compound interest would be you'd
have to serve millions of people at a
high enough level of value in order to
generate billions of dollars because
everything at least in the world of
capitalism is transactional and look am
your and for me what's really funny
about it is the the effort behind it in
a good way that's why the honey Empire
that's why we caught you know I'll
probably write that book like about
Vayner like we're doing it in such a
good way and we're winning like there's
a you know this was always my problem
Steve Jobs that reputation that you have
to be a dick to be Steve Jobs led to I
watched my friends as Steve's career
exploded I watched my friends in Silicon
Valley become dicks and that's that's
what's that's what probably matched in
my brain Roberto of me going ham on who
I actually am around cotton you know
Roberta what you had the luxury of
knowing that has become a little more
obvious in the last two years because I
found my contents unfolded or the last
four years with d-roc and vlogging you
can get a little bit deeper you can see
nuances you kind already knew that I was
a nice person yes
I'm an aggressive communicator which
makes all the people that are here like
my girlfriend my brother yeah all that I
got it I understand I'm a pathetic brown
military dude so I could parse that yeah
you that is easy for you but we also
knew the truth of my humanity yes but
but and I kind of held that back the
same way like like even that it was
actually uncomfortable in me to say
about the mask things earlier as I grew
why'd I say like it's really I don't
talk about my nonprofit world am i under
promote pension promise and charity yeah
I'll talk about any of the philanthropic
things I do
I don't like publicly tweet out my
donations to this thing or that thing
with the exception of team trees because
I had more people yeah yep yep
reconsidering that is an insight I just
think it's I think it's important that
people know that you can be a
millionaire and I hate that term but
that's exactly what I'm gonna say that
you could be a millionaire doing it the
right way and being kind and I don't and
I think that we got to a place in
culture when people didn't believe that
and I want to put that on my and and
then comma cuz that's for one group I
want a hole I want I want everybody to
know that $36,000 a year happy is
winning in life it is like how much do
you think how much do you think that
like some of the people not believing
things is style over substance meaning
there are people who like either like
one like the Steve Jobs being a dick
thing stylistically though like he to
the masses seemed like you know one way
but then in the micro relationships it's
known that he was like another way and
so it looked good to have jobs it's
Christian Mike yeah I call a Christopher
Columbus mmm we loved Christmas Columbus
in this world until about 20 years ago
right you know I'd rather be respected
long after I'm gone
then right now I think it I mean it
matters like it matters to me and I very
much pick up on the argument from other
people being like what are you talking
about like I want to be happy now and
I'm like I understand what makes me
happy is building a legacy that is
admired the end well doing everything
again you you're intentionally you're
doing things again for thinking about
the funeral and thinking after how
you're gone and thinking about how
people talking about kids again it's
like you know
like Steve Jobs kind of got it at the
end and had regrets about like the cons
I don't want to be that guy he I don't
would be the guy I don't want to be I
don't want to vent this I don't wanna be
that guy yeah
I mire him tremendously I'm not [ __ ]
on somebody's past she don't wanna be
that guy yeah I think that people have a
problem reconciling their ambition
versus their attitude because how you
how you play the game matters and the
thing is we're we're we're aggressively
in a culture and taught in a culture but
I think that's from scarcity I think
from scarcity people have a zero sum
game mentality a win at all harder to
say that's why people even demonize
successful people because that you could
only have one if it was at my expense or
the expense of someone like me Berto
Roberto I've built 5,000 agencies
because I put out so much free content
and decks people built agencies on new
packages
I know tons of people got it I believe
in abundance I believe in love yeah I
think I gotta go over I got a [ __ ]
important client call it was too much
fun I love you this was a lot of fun
yeah I appreciate you man thanks for
having me
doctors happy happy happy in Berto uh
Dustin thank you for being on the ones
and twos these episodes huh
so somebody say this is like a mini
podcast we're like doing it like we're
doing it doing it doing it well yeah do
you know what that reference was no read
the comments doing it doing it doing it
well you don't know you young [ __ ]
awesome oh geez tell them what it is
there it is that LL Cool J which is way
older anyway I appreciate everybody I
hope you enjoyed it please take a
screenshot of this right now please sign
up for why text we go out in an hour an
uncanny Chardonnay for under 20 bucks
this is a my one commercial during tea
time for my pops I will never forget for
my pops it would mean the world to me
and I mean the actual world to me that
if you buy wine on the internet or if
you buy wine that you sign up for wine
text calm
the best deals you'll ever see I work on
them every day with my best friend
Brandon and empathy wines
the winery I started that isn't it's
really fun to be in fact my roots sports
cards and wine but why in Texas bonkers
one deal a day today's a super famous
Chardonnay like the kind that you see on
the restaurant list for 100 bucks for 19
bucks and change like you should buy a
case and drink it all summer see ya okay
so team Gary has made a lot of content
over the years but what's your favorite
piece of content those makes a great
question
my favorite content by far is I'm
considering doing a vaynermedia
operation stay-at-home day once a week
forever because I'm I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day and
sometimes at a month